And that's how Map Reduce works. let's summarize. The
Mappers are just little programs that each deal with
a relatively small amount of data, and work in
parallel. We call that output the Intermediate Records. That's what
we were writing on our index cards. Hadoop deals
with all data in the form of key and
value. So these records are actually keys and values.
In our example, the key was the store name and
the value was the sale total for each
particular piece of input. Once the Mappers have finished,
a phase of Map Reduce called the Shuffle
and Sort takes place. The Shuffle is the movement
of the intermediate records from the Mappers to
the Reducers. The Sort is the fact that the
Reducers will organize these sets of records, in our
case these piles of index cards, into sorted order.
Finally, each Reducer works on one set of records at a time, or one pile of
cards. It gets the key and then a list of all the values. In our case, a store
like New York City. And in all the
sales for that store, it processes those values in
some way. In our case, we were adding up
the sales. Then it writes out the final results.